can you get a sense of Google cloud
platform machine learning products in
just a few minutes let's find out
[Music]
despite all the attention lately
machine learning still remains somewhat
difficult to build maintain and deploy
thankfully for you Google cloud platform
puts a lot of that behind the scenes so
you don't have to worry about it so what
does the hello world of ml look like
when you don't have to write the neural
nets yourself simply calling the vision
API to describe what it finds in the
picture as a leader in machine learning
Google cloud offers several high quality
pre trained models via api's that can
easily be consumed by developers
regardless of the language they use or
the nature of their application
developers can invoke the API directly
or using one of the idiomatic client
libraries available in numerous
programming languages here we invoke the
API directly from the product
description page from this image the API
can detect a broad set of labels provide
dominant colors and other image
properties it can also extract text
identify entities such as landmarks
celebrities logos or news events along
millions of entities that it supports it
can also moderate content such as all of
your apps user generated content in
addition to the vision API GCP offers
pre-trained models for text-to-speech
speech to text natural language
translate all via easy-to-use api's now
pre-trained models are amazingly easy to
use as we've seen but they're not
trained on your set of data this is
where a cloud auto email comes in cloud
auto email is here to enable developers
with limited machine learning expertise
to train high quality models specific to
their business needs by leveraging
Google's state-of-the-art transfer
learning and neural architecture search
technology cloud auto email provides a
simple graphical user interface
for you to train evaluate improve and
deploy models based on your own data
you're only a few minutes away from your
own custom machine learning model now
the ML API is and cloud auto ml are
great when you want to use or build upon
a pre train model that Google already
has training for but what if your needs
are beyond that well that basically
requires training your own models with
your own data sets on your own virtual
machines and I don't know about you but
I don't always have time for that which
is why I use cloud deep learning VM
image these Google compute engine
instances come pre-installed with the
latest versions of tensorflow
pi torch and scikit-learn you can also
add cloudy pu and GPU support with a
single click this image also comes with
the latest software drivers and
third-party dependencies including the
latest GPU software and is available
using the GCP marketplace from the
console or using the command line if
you'd like to get the operations out of
the way and focus on your models
consider using cloud AI platform which
offers fully managed training and
prediction services for developers and
data scientists you can build your
models with multiple ML frameworks
including site get learn XG boosts
Kerris and of course tensorflow
cloud AI platform trains any model at
large scale on a managed cluster hyper
tune is a unique feature that enables
you to reach better results faster by
automatically tuning deep learning hyper
parameters cloudy high platform then
offers online predictions adjusting to
any request rate coming from your ml
enabled applications and thus so through
a secure web endpoint batch predictions
are also supported for really
cost-effective inference from
asynchronous apps whether you're new to
machine learning or you're already an
expert GCP has a variety of tools to
help you from pre trained ml models
accessible via a simple API call
to customizing models with Auto ml to
training and serving a custom tensorflow
model using compute engine or a cloudy
eye platform consider taking free code
labs linked in the description below to
explore these products check out the
compute and Big Data overview episodes
and look forward to the upcoming video
on big data storage and processing
please like subscribe comment and share
see you soon for another GCP essentials
video
[Music]